I haven't written some articles about
the state of the film industry
especially for indie films you tell us
what this means for filmmakers and how
are things changing yeah well it means
something that filmmakers know already
it's really tough out there it's so hard
and the difficulty is part of the
frustration because I don't think
there's ever been a time when there has
been such an imbalance between so much
good quality work over here not only in
narrative movies but especially in
documentary movies I think documentary
movies now often blow narrative movies
away such an imbalance of amazing
quality work over here and this tiny
little pin hole through which these
boobs are trying to get to find their
audience it's just crazy i don't and i
also don't know any other any other
market any other pursuit where there's
so much amazing product if you will over
here and so little ability for customers
to come and get it over here and that's
the state of the affairs that we're in
right now so what do we see happening
why do we see changing i think a lot of
the things that you've alluded to there
are increasing distribution challenge
channels that are out there for
independent filmmakers which are not all
fee at racal a lot of which are online
it's never been easier to get people to
see your movie than today it's never
been harder to get people to pay to see
your movie than today and we still don't
have those models working yet I think
it's going to another couple of years
before we start to see some models that
really allow filmmakers to begin to
monetize their work better the other
thing is what I spoke about before I
think that lowering your ceiling for
success and really understanding
tionally that if you can get into
theatre as being in 500 North hundred
screens is really great success and feel
terrific about that because that is your
success I think that's breakthrough
success and it is break that a success
that will get noticed by larger and
larger players in the movie game do you
think the theater-going experience is
going away do you think that as gas
increases and the cost to find
babysitter and all that that goes along
with going out to the movies goes up
that will just resort to just these
commentators your world well what the
statistics tell us that attendance has
been going down steeply every year since
the end of the Second World War it's
moving it not not movie box office movie
box office is going up because it now
could cost $17 to go to the grove on a
Saturday night for a 3d movie which is
shocking so they're increasing the
ticket prices but the attendance is
there's no one like this so I hate to
say that but I don't see that trend
changing I just see attendance
continuing its downward trend I don't
think it's ever going to flatline but
it's going to keep going down
you